he's up for Best Actor Oscar tonight
please welcome two-time Academy Award
nominee Leonardo DiCaprio
today's reality television craze owes
its Genesis to the documentary for
decades documentary filmmakers have
captured life's beauty and drama and
stories that simply ask that we look a
little closer at the world around us
this year the five nominated films for
Best Documentary Feature explore
subjects ranging from sexual abuse to
traditional and modern artistic
expression to fast food and now please
join me in welcoming this year's
outstanding nominees for Best
Documentary Feature
born into brothels Ross Kaufmann and
Zhanna Brisky the story of the weeping
camel Luigi Fulani
and byamba Soren Dava supersize me
Morgan Spurlock
Tupac Resurrection Lauren lazin and
Carolyn Ali twist of faith
Kirby dick and Eddie Schmidt
and the Oscar goes to born into brothels
Ross Kaufmann and Zhanna Brisky this is
the first Academy Award nomination for
Ross Hoffman and Zanna brigade
Tom Hanks's right this thing is heavy a
little gold man just what we always
wanted um we thank you so much this is
an incredible incredible honor
we thank the kids they're watching in
Calcutta we thank you so much we love
you very much we'd like to thank HBO the
best place on the planet for
documentaries think film doing an
incredible job with this film the
Sundance Institute Diane wireman we love
you
jerilyn white Dreyfuss our executive
producer and panel of all our
co-executive producer thank you so much
and I'd like to thank Zanna Brisky this
amazing woman right next to me
she uh she's incredible